[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon histoire commence il y a seulement deux ans j'étais
chez mes grands-parents en train d'étudier pour mes
examens de janvier comme tout bon élève
ouais c'est une session d'étude assez intense
mais à ce moment-là j'étais plus dans une
session de procrastination intense tu sais
ça  moment où vous regardez tant de
vidéos sur des sujets vraiment intéressants
qui n'ont absolument rien à voir avec
ce que vous devez réellement étudier
bien c'était moi mais c'est au cours d'une de
ces intenses crises de boulimie à regarder une série de
vidéos que je suis tombé sur une
conférence TED en particulier  une femme de 23 ans
appelée Lauren singer qui en l'espace de
trois ans avait produit l'équivalent
d'un pot Mason comme vous avez vu des ordures et
j'ai dit que j'étais il y a un collage alors imaginez mon
visage quand je descends et j'ai réalisé
que j'avais  Je me sers
un jus d'orange par jour avec une paille en plastique
depuis trois semaines trois semaines
fois sept jours, c'est un total de 21
pailles en plastique et c'est le total de
ces 21 plasti  c des pailles qui m'ont fait
réaliser une chose importante si vous
voulez changer le monde vous devez d'
abord vous changer ne demandez pas seulement ce que nos
politiciens peuvent faire pour aider à sauver la
planète mais aussi ce que vous pouvez faire pour aider à
sauver la
planète je crois chacun  d'entre nous a le
pouvoir de changer le monde et sinon le
monde dans son ensemble votre monde individuel
votre communauté individuelle et c'est l'
addition de ces mondes individuels qui
changera le monde dans son ensemble
93% des
oiseaux marins qui avaient été analysés avaient du
plastique injecté et que 43% des
déchets que l'on trouve sur les
plages européennes sont des plastiques à usage unique des plastiques
qui ne sont utilisés qu'une seule fois par nous puis
jetés on ne s'en rend pas compte mais  le
plastique se reproduit quotidiennement ça s'ajoute à
ce gros tas et le simple fait de
jeter quelque chose ne veut pas dire que ça
s'en va c'est tout simplement hors
de vue et c'est quand j'ai réalisé
ça que j'ai besoin de choses  pour changer, je
vous dis ceci, mais nous savons tous que cela fait
peur, nous savons tous qu'il y a un
problème de plastique, nous savons tous qu'il y a un
problème climatique, comment cela se fait-il alors que nous
ne sommes qu'un si petit nombre de personnes
qui font activement quelque chose à
ce sujet  n'est-il pas temps que nous fassions tous tout notre
possible pour changer la situation autour des idées qui
existent dans la tête de tout le monde et je suis sûr
qu'en écoutant toutes ces conférences TED
ce soir, vous avez au moins eu une bonne idée,
la question maintenant est de savoir ce que vous ferez
avec  cette idée
prise dans les soucis à court terme de la
vie, nous avons tendance à oublier ce qui
compte vraiment pour nous, l'historien et activiste
Robert Swan a déclaré que la plus grande menace pour
notre planète
est la croyance que quelqu'un d'autre la
sauvera et comme je l'ai dit pris dans le
soucis à court terme de nos vies individuelles,
nous avons tendance à oublier ce qui
compte vraiment pour nous, mais nous avons aussi tendance à oublier
les gros problèmes en laissant ces deux autres
personnes penser qu'elles le résoudront
bien Je suis ici ce soir pour vous montrer et
prouver à  tu  que vous pouvez être
quelqu'un d'autre à partir de cette citation, vous pouvez
changer le monde et c'est quand j'ai
réalisé que même si j'étais écologique
en théorie, j'avais besoin de mettre cette
déclaration en actions concrètes, le simple
fait d'avoir une idée ne suffit pas alors
pour partager une petite histoire personnelle en
fait et l'histoire qui a été le
déclencheur de cette prise de conscience le déclencheur
de l'action eh bien je vous le partagerai
un jour j'ai reçu un appel de ma mère
Fannie un colis de vingt cinq kilogrammes
vient d'être livré à notre  à la maison pouvez-vous
s'il vous plaît m'expliquer ce qui se passe ma
mère vous avez dû voir son visage quand elle s'est
rendu compte que cet emballage de 25 kilogrammes
contenait 600 pailles en acier inoxydable
et même si vous pourriez penser que je savais
exactement ce que je voulais faire avec ces
600 pailles  Je ne savais vraiment pas je veux dire
bien sûr j'avais une idée mais comment
j'allais la mettre en oeuvre comment j'allais
concrétiser cette idée je n'en avais absolument aucune
idée et c'est quand j'ai raconté cette petite
anecdote à la fille assise ne  xt à moi
à l'université que d'ailleurs je n'avais
jamais parlé avant qu'elle ait vu le
potentiel de cette idée
Manuela est devenue la co-fondatrice de nos
projets appelés Wow
qui est l'acronyme de qu'en est-il des déchets
la plus large équipe l'avait parce qu'elle à la
place  de voir le gros tas et les
gros problèmes dans le monde elle a vu ce que
vous pourriez faire en tant qu'individu lentement mais
sûrement chaque jour pour changer votre petite
communauté maintenant qu'est-ce que c'est
exactement Wow l'idée de base est vraiment
simple et c'est quelque chose que j'ai réalisé le
long  mon parcours les gens n'ont pas le
temps ne sont tout simplement pas assez intéressés pour se
soucier de l'environnement au
quotidien alors nous avons proposé de changer
cette question si les gens ne
voulaient pas être écologiques ou n'avaient pas le
temps de penser  à propos de l'écologie
pour eux alors nous avons pris les 600
balades en acier inoxydable et sommes allés d'un
restaurant à l'autre et avons proposé
ces petites pailles comme alternatives aux
pailles en plastique à usage unique maintenant notre
solution au lieu de  utiliser est une
paille en plastique
utiliser une paille en acier inoxydable mais je suis
conscient que le
problème du plastique à usage unique en plastique est beaucoup plus large que de
simples pailles en plastique, mais la
paille en plastique et notre paille en acier inoxydable
servent de symbole à tout ce que les
gens peuvent faire dans  leur vie quotidienne pour
mener une vie moins gaspilleuse notre
objectif ultime est de rendre ce
mode de vie durable et écologique
plus facile et même moins cher que celui qui
gaspille et je suis convaincu que nous
atteindrons cet objectif à la simple vitesse à
laquelle le problème de la paille en plastique s'est propagé à
travers  les pays tant de
pays parlent de
routes en plastique, même les médias sont la preuve que lorsque nous
prenons collectivement des mesures sur nos
problèmes, nous pouvons obtenir des
résultats significatifs honnêtement et vraiment surpris
quand je pense à l'impact Wow
ça a juste commencé il y a un an et
aujourd'hui Wow  s'est propagé dans trois
pays différents, sept villes et plus
qu'aujourd'hui, 90 restaurants
qui, avec nous, ont décidé de  bannir
les pailles en plastique de leurs restaurants
mais ce n'est pas tout je ne suis pas seulement un
entrepreneur je suis aussi et très fortement
un écologiste pensez à moi comme
étant l'imprimeur vert imprimeur en
français veut dire preneur et je pense que c'est
important que vous chacun de nous  prend des
mesures et oui nous avons le pouvoir avec
notre argent avec les actions que nous faisons quotidiennement
pour montrer aux grandes institutions que nous
ne changerons pas que nous ne méprisons
pas ce qui se passe en ce moment je
veux que vous imaginiez quelque chose
imaginez-vous après un  longue et dure
journée de travail pas difficile à imaginer
tu vas dans ta salle de bain et tu tournes le
haut de ta baignoire parce que tu as mérité
un bon bain chaud maintenant ce n'est pas très
collage d'ailleurs alors essaye de ne pas le
faire trop souvent  mais vous ouvrez le robinet
et vous oubliez ce robinet et vous
revenez précipitamment dans votre salle de bain en
trouvant votre salle de bain complètement inondée
que faites-vous faites-vous d'abord et levez
des seaux et nettoyez le désordre
immédiatement ou faites-vous fi  fermez-le d'abord
, puis commencez à nettoyer le gâchis,
levez la main et le public
qui tournerait cet onglet en premier ouais bien sûr
une question très sensée mais j'aimerais
établir un parallèle maintenant pourquoi ne fermons-nous pas
cet onglet de la production de plastique  d'abord et
je suis le plus grand défenseur
et je vous promets que je suis le plus grand
défenseur des nettoyages de plage et des
marques de mode utilisant des plastiques et des
tissus recyclables pour créer de nouveaux produits J'en
porte un ce soir mais mais et
il y a un gros mais euh donc je  n'ont pas le
meilleur mais ne pensez-vous pas qu'en
parallèle nous devrions simplement fermer que Wow le
fait en empêchant les gens d'aller dans
nos restaurants utiliser ou même de donner
cette possibilité d'utiliser des pailles en plastique vous
allez dans l'un de nos restaurants partenaires
votre boisson  est automatiquement servi
sans cela mais nous avons besoin de plus Wow dans ce
monde imaginez si chacun d'entre vous
dans cette salle et dans le monde qui avait une
idée bouillante sur la façon de changer le monde
mettrait des actions concrètes sur eux
imaginez si  vous Monsieur créeriez le
Wow de chaque hypocalorique et imaginez si
vous, madame, créeriez le puits des
plats à emporter, imaginez seulement l'impact que nous
pourrions avoir et j'ai créé mon Wow
le procrastinateur que je suis donc il n'y a
absolument aucune raison pour que vous ne puissiez pas
créer le vôtre Barrack  Obama a dit que nous sommes
la première génération à ressentir l'impact
du changement climatique, mais nous sommes aussi la
dernière à pouvoir faire quelque chose,
alors faisons quelque chose, agissons,
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]